the ravens have a chip on their shoulder
because god forbid we notice that their
receivers aren't very good they can't
attract great receivers because they
don't throw the football very well but
don't tell that to general manager eric
decosta that makes him a little bit
salty here he is from earlier today
but we want to have good players at
every position you know i'm aware that
there's some fan discontent with our
wide receivers and our drafting and all
that i mean
but in in general i look at our record
and how we win games and how we play
football and i'm proud of the team i
know coach is proud i know joe is proud
so we've got some really good young
receivers it's insulting to these guys
when they hear that we don't have any
receivers it's quite insulting i'm
insulted by it too to be honest so i
think we've got some guys that want to
show everybody what they can do
exactly motivation
use any and all slights actual or
perceived to get these guys motivated
and he said they have some good young
receivers why do they have good young
receivers because the only way they can
get receivers is to draft them because
the free agents don't want to go there
sami watkins did because it's not like
he had a bunch of suitors clamoring at
his door juju smith schuster took less
money to stay in pittsburgh guys don't
want to go to an offense where the ball
isn't being thrown and that's not a
lamar jackson slight that is a raven's
offense slight
that's what they do look at that past
attempts per game last in the league
pass yards per game last in the league
that's because they run it so well
something's got to give there's only one
football and when you skew toward the
run you're not going to pass and when
you don't pass you're not going to
attract receivers to your team period
yeah exactly look i mean they were the
league's best rushing team they had a
they had their quarterback go over a
thousand yards rushing for the second
year in a row it's never happened before
so there is a reason why they are still
effective on offense it's the run game
but i think when you are 32nd dead last
in both passing yards and passing
attempts it means you're really not even
trying to throw the ball all that much
and again when you run the ball as
effectively as they do it makes sense so
i get what decosta is saying you know
i'm proud of the team we're still
winning games of course they're winning
games and they may or may not be the
best team in that division i think that
you can certainly make an argument that
they still are however
i think to say you know we have these
good young wide receivers and they're
insulted look marquis brown had 58
catches for 769 yards and eight
touchdowns last year that led the team
in yards and also he tied for the team
lead in receptions with mark andrews and
in order to find your next wide receiver
on that list you have to go all the way
down to willie snead who had 33 catches
for 432 yards i'm sorry you're insulted
eric decosta but my man
that is not effective wide receiving
because you're not throwing the ball so
i don't know how you i i just
that's fine that you want to be insulted
and that yeah you may have good young
white outs but you at least got to get
something more out of that passing game
man
i remember it was hollywood brown who at
one point during the season during one
of their stretches where things weren't
going well how to tweet criticizing the
way he was being used and finally later
in the season they began to develop
creative ways to get the ball in
hollywood brown's hands that's the
challenge it's a challenge of coaching
you got one football you got 11 players
find a way to get the ball into the
hands of all of the skill position
players not just the ones who
who you know
are going to gain yardage it's like that
play in madden that works all the time
you just keep doing it because it works
the problem is you could develop other
facets of your of your attack and you
just aren't trying because it's too easy
to go with those two or three plays that
work all the time so we'll see if they
can do it this year with marquis brown
entering his third season with sammy
watkins on the team we'll see if they
continue to develop and also whoever
they draft who won't have any choice but
to join the ravens in another year that
is very deep at the draft position
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports